.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Marco Caimi ist Männerarzt.
Er beschäftigt sich mit dem Mannsein
in all seinen Facetten
und mit der Frage:
"Wann ist man ein Mann?"
Um es einfach zu sagen:
Wenn er als Mann weiss,
was er will -
zum Wohle aller.
Also nicht auf den Schultern
von Berufskollegen, der Familie,
seinem Partner, seiner Partnerin.
Er steht geerdet auf dem Boden und
weiss, was seine Vorstellungen sind.
Das ist für mich Mensch sein,
Mann sein. Das ist für mich stimmig.
Keine Ellenbogen oder Bandenchecks,
wie man im Eishockey sagen würde.
* Schleppende Musik *
Legen Sie sich bitte hin und machen
den linken Oberarm möglichst frei.
Es waren die Folgen der Finanzkrise,
die Marco Caimi dazu bewogen haben,
seine Männerpraxis zu gründen.
Reihenweise brachen Manager in seinem
Sprechzimmer damals in Tränen aus.
Er beschloss, sich fortan nicht mehr
nur um die Männerkörper zu kümmern,
denen zu wenig Sorge getragen wird,
sondern auch um das männliche
Innenleben. Um den ganzen Mann halt.
139 zu 82.
Bei Ihrem Jahrgang
dürfte der obere etwas tiefer sein,
aber beim letzten Mal
lag er noch über 140.
Der untere ist mit 85
ziemlich zufriedenstellend.
Wie ist es so mit den Männern,
schauen sie sich heute besser?
Ja.
- Ja?
Ja, also v.a. seine Generation.
Die in den 90ern Geborenen zeigen
ein erhöhtes Körperbewusstsein
und schauen sich besser.
Die alten weissen Männer wie mich
muss man noch nacherziehen.
Das ist eigentlich die Aufgabe
der Frauen.
Sie haben oft noch das Gefühl,
der Indianer kenne keinen Schmerz
und an etwas sterbe man sowieso.
Die jüngere Generation wird schon
körpersensibler. Das ist auch gut.
Die Männer holen auf,
auch in einem weiteren Geschäftszweig
der Männerpraxis.
Das ist das Hobby
von meiner Frau und mir.
Wir wollen nicht nur gescheit reden,
sondern auch manuell etwas machen.
Das ist unsere ästhetische Medizin.
Was heisst das? Botox?
Botox - sehr selten.
Eigentlich nur bei Männern,
die sehr böse schauen,
mit einer tiefen Zornesfalte.
Werden die Männer eitler?
Ja.
Nicht eitler im Sinne
von narzisstisch gestört,
aber sie legen - generell gesagt -
etwas mehr Wert aufs Äussere.
Ich finde das auch etwas Schönes.
Wenn sich daraus
etwas mehr Selbstbewusstsein
oder mehr Sicherheit beim Auftreten
entwickelt, soll man das machen.
Sie können wieder aufstehen und
noch einmal zu mir ins Büro kommen.
Prima! Also ...
Sie wissen, was wir abgemacht haben.
* Kirchlicher Gesang *
Auch ausserhalb seiner Praxis
dreht sich bei Marco Caimi
alles ums Mannsein.
In Workshops, schon vor sieben
Jahren, hier im Kloster Engelberg.
Wer, meine Herren, nimmt
ab und zu oder regelmässig Viagra?
Der summt jetzt.
* Vereinzeltes Summen *
* Lachen *
Und wer noch nie so etwas
genommen hat, der summt jetzt.
* Mehrfaches Summen *
... war am Lautesten.
Wir kommen später noch zu Sex und
Ehrlichkeit, etwa im dritten Akt.
Die Teilnehmer am Workshop
Gipfeltreffen im Kloster Engelberg
nennen sich Brüder auf Zeit.
Sie alle wollen sich ein Wochenende
lang unter ihresgleichen austauschen
und - so der Titel des Seminars -
ganz Mann sein.
Frei von den Ansprüchen ihrer Frauen,
Familien und Vorgesetzten.
* Kirchlicher Gesang *
Bisher hiess es immer,
als Mann müsse man der Schnellste,
Beste und Stärkste sein.
Jetzt heisst es,
er könne überhaupt nicht zuhören.
Solche Sachen
sind für einen Mann total neu.
Zuhören? Ja. Okay.
Einerseits nach Hause kommen:
mit dem Wüstenstaub, dem Rauch
des Lagerfeuers, staubigen Stiefeln
und dem herabhängenden Colt.
Gleichzeitig sollte man
einen Seelenmassage machen,
mit den Kindern spielen
und Kuchen backen.
Wir müssten sehr vielseitig sein.
Da müssen wir Männer schauen,
dass wir uns nicht verlieren.
* Kirchlicher Gesang *
Bei unserer Generation
ist überhaupt nichts mehr definiert.
Die Frauen sind emanzipiert
und wir müssen damit umgehen.
Ich suche oft nach meiner Rolle.
* Stimmengewirr *
Ziel des Gipfeltreffens ist: ganz
Mann sein. Was heisst das für Sie?
In erster Linie
eine gewisse Entspannung
in die männliche Hektik zu bringen,
die wir sehr lange
selbst gemacht haben.
Nach dem alten,
klassischen Rollenbild.
Von der Erziehung her.
Von der männlichen Härte,
dem starken Geschlecht.
Dank der letzten 41 Jahre
Emanzipation
ist eine zusätzliche Komponente
dazugekommen.
Das ist die weibliche Seite.
Das sind die weiblichen
Anforderungen, Erwartungshaltungen
und auch die eigenen Interessen.
Die Frauen waren -
wenn ich das so sagen darf -
einfach ziemlich rasch
auf der Überholspur.
Bei uns machte es "wusch" und
die Frauen bogen vorne wieder ein.
Wir wussten gar nicht, was passiert.
So, ich bitte euch,
für 1 Min. die Augen zu schliessen.
Überlegt euch 1 Min. lang
mit geschlossenen Augen,
was Sexualität für ihn bedeutet.
* Schritte *
Das Allerschwierigste
ist der allererste Schritt,
zu sagen,
wie Sexualität zu definieren ist.
Sitzen beide
mit einem weissen Blatt hin,
kann eine Diskussion in Gang kommen.
Man kann vorsichtig beginnen
und sagen,
man mache Sexualität als Spielfeld.
Alles, was nicht in Frage kommt,
die persönlichen No-Gos,
schreibt man neben das Spielfeld.
Man kann sich nicht vorstellen, sie
jemals im Leben über Bord zu werfen.
Dadurch erhält der andere
eine klare Ansage.
Das vermindert die Scham.
Es kann sogar produktiv werden,
es kann lustig werden,
es kann erotisch werden.
Schreibt eure wichtigste,
sexuelle Fantasie auf!
Auf dem Spielfeld
kann man Zonen machen.
In der Hauptzone steht, worauf man
wirklich nicht verzichten will.
In den Nebenzonen steht,
was verhandelbar ist.
Sexualität muss man auch verhandeln.
Wir Männer verhandeln nicht,
wir holen es uns auswärts.
Deshalb macht diese Industrie
so unglaubliche Umsätze.
Ich möchte die Leute auffordern,
daraus keinen Kriegsplatz,
sondern ein Spielfeld zu machen.
"Eine zweite Frau in der Beziehung,
Dreier - etc."
Aha.
"Geiles, langes Küssen
und dabei geblasen werden."
Ui, ui, ui.
"Sex mit mehreren Frauen
gleichzeitig und ausdauernd."
Hoppla.
"Tüchtig vom Leder ziehen, am
Küchentisch bei offenem Fenster."
Das ist auch interessant.
Marco Caimi hat eine Fachausbildung
in Psychiatrie
und bietet Gesprächstherapien an.
Guten Morgen, Frau Eichenberger.
In dieser Funktion kümmert er sich
nicht nur um Männer,
sondern auch um deren Frauen.
Er begleitet Scheidungsprozesse,
coacht bei der Suche nach Lösungen,
wenn Drittpartner im Spiel sind
oder unterstützt ganz einfach
die Beziehungspflege
in Langzeitbeziehungen.
Wir haben uns etwa
ein halbes Jahr nicht gesehen.
Als Hausaufgabe
hatten wir beschlossen ...
Die Hausaufgabe war,
an den definierten Zielpunkten
etwas weiterzukommen.
Wir sind auf dem Weg, Herr Caimi,
wir sind auf dem Weg.
Sylvia und Christian Eichenberger
sind seit 25 Jahren verheiratet.
In regelmässigen Abständen buchen sie
Coaching-Termine bei Marco Caimi,
um an ihrer Beziehung zu arbeiten.
Dabei geht es um die Diskussion
von gemeinsamen und individuellen
Zielen und Werten,
um Work-Life-Balance,
um Gemeinsamkeiten und Eigenheiten,
um Nähe und Distanz.
Wir schauen, dass unsere
Finanzplanung geordnet ist.
Man hat andere Dinge,
die man irgendwie aufbaut.
Uns ist die Beziehung wichtig.
Auch da wollen wir
den Moment nicht verpassen,
dass plötzlich
einer von uns abdriftet,
weil es zu langweilig ist,
weil es immer das Gleiche ist,
weil man es immer so gemacht hat.
Dann wird es plötzlich langweilig -
und das wollten wir vermeiden.
Wenn wir beim Körperlichen und
Respekt sind, geht es auch um Nähe,
um Intimität, um Sexualität.
Ihr habt mir gesagt,
dass ihr auch diesbezüglich
sehr gut ins Gespräch gekommen seid.
Ich bin selbst erstaunt,
dass wir das machen konnten,
dass wir in der Lage sind,
miteinander
so offen zu kommunizieren,
dass das auch gelungen ist.
Die Wünsche sind unterschiedlich,
aber es gibt eine Einigkeit:
Die körperliche Nähe ist ein Thema.
Das ist ein Thema.
Mir ist es wichtiger als der Frau,
aber es ist für uns gemeinsam
ein Thema.
Schwierig war der erste Schritt,
zu sagen:
"Das wollen wir angehen,
das wollen wir besprechen."
Das habe ich gelernt.
Zur Offenheit gehört auch,
dazu zu stehen, was man will.
Nicht schon im Voraus
Rücksicht nehmen,
sondern den eigenen Standpunkt
auch einbringen.
... Themen gehabt.
Als Frau
in einer Männerpraxis sitzen,
einem Männerarzt
das Herz ausschütten.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
er ist ein Macho.
Fühlen Sie sich gut aufgehoben,
ernst genommen?
Schaut er nicht nur,
dass es den Männern gutgeht?
Ja, doch. Ich finde schon.
Er kann gut zuhören.
Er kann einen wirklich
gut wahrnehmen.
Er kann auch auf einen eingehen.
Ich finde das schon, doch.
Ich habe eigentlich
auch gar keine Hemmungen.
Ich kann ihm gut
meine Anliegen erzählen.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
er nimmt mich ernst.
Er wirkt etwas machohaft.
Ja, natürlich,
aber das ist auch gut so.
Das darf sein.
Ich finde das toll.
Was heisst es für Sie,
ganz Mann zu sein?
Was ist Ihre Definition davon,
ein guter Mann zu sein?
Auf die Familie bezogen?
Da möchte ich ein Vorbild sein.
Für mich selbst
möchte ich gute Zeichen setzen.
Im Beruf, privat und ehrenamtlich
möchte ich gute, nachhaltige,
sinnvolle Zeichen setzen.
D.h. für mich auch, ein guter
Partner für meine Frau zu sein.
Vielen Dank.
- Merci.
So, bitte schön.
- Danke schön.
Nach Ihnen.
(Frau) Kommen Sie gut nach Hause.
- Danke.
Alles Gute!
Im Empfangsbereich der Praxis sitzt
Marco Caimis Frau, Daniela Bürgin.
Die beiden kennen sich
seit über 30 Jahren
und sind seit zehn Jahren ein Paar,
leben und arbeiten zusammen.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass es uns sehr gut gelingt.
Wir haben zu Beginn
Freunde und Bekannte befragt,
weil wir nicht wussten,
wie das funktionieren soll.
Wir haben Freunde,
die Metzger oder Apotheker sind,
die zusammen arbeiten.
Es ist sehr schön und gut.
Jeder hat seinen Kompetenzbereich.
Sie ist meine Finanz-
und Organisationschefin
und macht die ganze Diagnostik und
den Vampirismus - die Blutentnahmen.
Ich bin mit den Patienten
im Sprechzimmer.
Wenn die Kompetenzen klar verteilt
sind, dann geht das gut.
Liebe Mitbrüder.
Wir kommen jetzt zur Fragerunde.
"Was Sie schon immer
eine Frau fragen wollten
und nie zu fragen trauten."
Ich darf euch Maya Onken vorstellen.
Zu den Männern im Kloster Engelberg
gesellt sich für einen
kurzen Auftritt Maya Onken -
die ihrerseits seit Jahren
mit Frauen arbeitet.
... nichtsdestotrotz
ist sie hierhergekommen.
Ich weiss nicht, ob euch bewusst
ist, dass eure Frauen ständig -
ihr denkt vielleicht,
Finanzen seien nicht ihr Ding -
einen Kontostand über euch führen.
* Raunen *
Da steht aber
nicht das effektive Salär.
Sondern alles, was ihr macht,
respektive eben nicht macht,
wird kontiert.
Also: ein Blumenstrauss,
das gibt 50 Punkte plus.
Vergessen, den Müll hinauszutragen:
minus 20 Punkte.
Ein nettes Wort am Abend:
"Schatz, wie war dein Tag?"
Plus 100 Punkte.
Kein nettes Wort am Abend: "Schatz,
wie war dein Tag?" Minus 200 Punkte.
Frauen sagen lange nichts.
Sie sagen einfach nichts.
Ihr habt keine Ahnung, dass ihr
schon lange im Minus seid.
Sie sind immer noch nett zu euch.
Sie hoffen, es kommt noch etwas.
Irgendwann
platzt der Frau der Kragen.
Sie präsentiert euch euren Konto-
stand, der absolut im Minus ist.
Das ist eigentlich der Punkt,
an dem ihr eingreifen könntet.
Fragt mal eure Frauen:
"Wie sieht bei dir
der aktuelle Kontostand aus?"
"Was gibt das, wenn ich arbeite
und das Geld nach Hause bringe,
wie viel ist dir das wert?"
Ihr würdet
euer blaues Wunder erleben,
wie unterschiedlich ihr kontiert.
Ein Ehering: "Du bist es." Und dann
ist gut, das reicht nicht.
Bei Frauen ist das nicht so.
Die wollen permanente Erneuerung,
permanente Liebesschwüre.
Das Punktesystem fand ich genial.
Ich werde meine Freundin
mal nach meinem Kontostand befragen.
Seminarteilnehmer Philipp
ist Marco Caimis Sohn.
Und seine damalige Freundin
wird im September seine Frau.
Der Dreh mit den beiden fällt
in die Zeit des Corona-Lockdowns
und findet per Skype statt.
Herr Caimi, Sie haben sich
beim letzten Film vorgenommen,
Ihre Freundin regelmässig
nach dem Kontostand zu fragen -
wie sieht er momentan aus?
Den aktuellsten kenne ich nicht, den
Auszug habe ich noch nicht bekommen.
Ich denke ... Er sollte gut sein.
Wir gehen gut miteinander um.
Können Sie das bestätigen,
Frau Künzler?
Auf alle Fälle.
Er hat in den letzten Jahren
ein Gefühl dafür entwickelt,
um zu merken,
wie sein Kontostand ist.
Oder?
Was gibt am meisten Pluspunkte?
Aha.
Am meisten Pluspunkte gibt es,
wenn ich überrascht werde -
darüber freue ich mich.
Oder wenn ich nach Hause komme
und schon alles bereit ist
für einen guten Start
ins Wochenende.
Das ist ein natürlicher Reflex.
Vielen Männern wurde - Entschuldi-
gung - auf den Schwanz getreten.
Das ist für mich ...
Es passt zum Ganzen.
Marco Caimi liebt die Provokation.
Sein Auftritt im "Club"
des Schweizer Fernsehens
sorgte letztes Jahr
für einiges Aufsehen.
Es ist, als würde man
magnetische Pole entmagnetisieren.
Ich bin froh ...
Man kann sich immer fragen ...
Sei mal ruhig, du machst mich nervös
mit deinem Brummeln.- Du mich auch.
Jetzt rede ich!
- Herr Caimi, Herr Theunert ...
Jetzt rede ich,
du bekommst den Redestab nachher.
Einer nach dem anderen.
Ich geh sonst raus, das geht mir
auf den Sack! Ehrlich.
Jetzt sei mal ruhig!
Ich habe die Sendeleitung gewarnt.
Man kann sich wundern ...
- (Barbara Lüthi) Das geschieht ...
Das Problem war ...
Der Zuschauer zu Hause merkt nicht,
dass dem, der nicht spricht,
das Mikrofon abgestellt wird.
Die Zuschauer zu Hause vor den
Bildschirmen bekamen nicht mit,
dass Herr Theunert permanent
aus einem halben Meter Abstand
seine Meinung kundtat, währenddessen
ich etwas Gescheites sagen sollte -
zu einem sehr schwierigen Thema.
Sie stehen zu Ihrer Reaktion,
auch aus heutiger Sicht?
Ja, selbstverständlich.
Ich glaube, ich versuche ...
Wie gesagt,
ich verdiene mein Geld mit zuhören.
In dieser Rolle ist es wichtig,
dass man die Leute ausreden lässt,
auch wenn man zwischendurch denkt:
"Muss ich mir das anhören?"
Das lässt
die Professionalität nicht zu.
Ich verlange aber auch
von der anderen Seite,
dass sie mich ausreden lässt.
Es war für mich nicht unangenehm,
und doch hatte ich
ein komisches Gefühl.
Das haben so viele Leute gesehen.
Wir haben eine Arztpraxis.
Ich hatte Angst,
dass es geschäftsschädigend ist.
Als wir nach Hause kamen, wurde
die Sendung gerade ausgestrahlt.
Als ich es
zum zweiten Mal gesehen habe,
war ich schon beruhigter und fand,
dass es nicht so schlecht war.
Gelassen auf diesen Auftritt
reagierte Caimis Sohn Philipp.
Es war typisch. Ich finde nicht,
dass er die Nerven verloren hat.
Es hat ihn einfach gestört.
Er hat dann einfach seine Meinung
gesagt. Sie war sehr direkt.
Ich kenne das nicht anders. Stört
ihn etwas, kann er sehr direkt sein
und kommuniziert das.
Danach ist es für ihn
auch wieder gut.
Er hat mit ihm nachher an der Bar
noch ein Bier getrunken.
So kenne ich ihn auch,
nachher ist wieder alles in Ordnung.
Es ist gesagt, man hofft
auf Korrektur und es ist erledigt.
Daniela Bürgin ist Marco Caimis drit-
te Ehefrau, er ist ihr zweiter Mann.
Beide haben sie
je zwei erwachsene Kinder.
* Vogelzwitschern *
(Philipp) Was ich von meinen Vater
habe, ist die Liebe zum Sport,
zum Fussball.
Was an ihm
auch typisch männlich ist ...
Man sagt, es sei typisch männlich:
sein Durchhaltewillen.
Er versuchte immer wieder
etwas Neues im Leben.
Er ging immer wieder Risiken ein,
auch noch im aktuellen Alter.
Das ist mir auch geblieben,
man sagt nicht einfach:
"Es funktioniert nicht,
dann geben wir auf."
Sondern: "Bleib dran,
es ist etwas Gutes. Mach weiter!"
Ganz Mann, ganz Frau?
Im Hause Caimi,
wie anderswo, Definitionssache.
Er ist kein Macho,
was immer Macho heisst
oder was man darunter versteht.
Er macht alles,
was ich hier zu Hause auch mache.
Es ist ein Geben und Nehmen.
Das ist für mich Männlichkeit - auf
der gleichen Ebene wie ich zu sein.
Was gefällt Ihnen
an der Weiblichkeit Ihrer Frau?
Ihre Erscheinung,
ihre Aura, ihr Charisma
entspricht einer Weiblichkeit,
die mich auch anspricht.
Ich muss mich nicht zwingen,
eine Weiblichkeit zu entdecken.
Es fluscht eigentlich.
Mit einer Portion Selbstbestimmung
in der Weiblichkeit.
Ich finde,
das tut mir als Mann auch gut.
Sie fordert mich -
relativ selten überfordert sie mich.
Das macht eigentlich Spass.
Sucht mal nach dem Punkt,
der zwischen dem Skrotum -
zu Deutsch der Hodensack -
und der analen Öffnung ist.
Sollte zu finden sein.
Drückt mit gewissen Nachdruck
auf den Punkt, 1 Min. lang.
Zum Schluss noch ein ganz eindeutiger
Zugang zum Thema Ganz Mann sein.
Ihr dürft die Hosen schliessen.
Wer jetzt schon eine Erektion hatte,
geht Kaffee trinken
und muss die weiteren Übungen
nicht mehr machen.
Zum Schluss machen wir
die Position des Löwen.
Wir atmen ein.
Ich mache es einmal vor.
* Marco Caimi brüllt laut,
die Teilnehmer lachen. *
* Husten *
Jetzt hätte ich gerne 18 Löwen.
* Tiefes Einatmen. *
Und ...
* Lautes Brüllen *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Andrea Werlen - 2020